in the 20 years that i've been
covering our border issues there was
always at least
one point of agreement on both sides of
the issue
that new immigrants should work hard to
speak english because doing so
would help ensure their success here and
also speed up assimilation
illegal immigrants who have roots in our
country and want to stay
should have to pay a meaningful penalty
for breaking the law
to pay their taxes to learn english i
think
learning english is not just important
for assimilation it's important for
economic success
if you've been here a certain amount of
time you've got a clean record
you're willing to pay a fine learn
english you have to pay taxes they have
to learn english
to become american citizens to be part
of the economy part of the system
learn english do all the things that we
think is important part of being an
american
i want to clap when i hear that well in
today's democrat party things are moving
so far and so far left and so fast
that the entire speak english sentiment
has become radioactive enter
liberal lion tom brokaw he was appearing
on meet the press yesterday
and a breath after he was frankly
stereotyping border enforcement
advocates
he had the nerve to say this
i also happen to believe that the
hispanics should work harder at
assimilation that's one of the things
i've been saying for a long time
you know that they ought not to be just
codified in their communities but
make sure that all their kids are
learning to speak english and that they
feel comfortable in the communities and
that's going to take outreach on both
sides frankly
how dare he say that speak english in
their
fierce outrage poured in almost
instantaneously especially from the 2020
herd
seeking an edge in the radical beauty
pageant
congressman joaquin castro tweeting to
brokaw
tom brokaw for a celebrated nbc news
journalist
who spent years chronicling american
society you seem
stunningly ignorant of the hispanic
community in this country
unfortunate to see xenophobia pass for
elevated political commentary
and that's not all folks it got worse
both
on and offline for brokaw despite his
numerous
and frankly embarrassing twitter
apologies
the idea that we think of american can
only speak english as if
spanish and other languages wasn't
always part of america is some ways
troubling there is absolutely nothing
wrong with speaking spanish
it's an antiquated view of our country
to think otherwise he's a little out of
touch
what he's saying is just absolutely not
true
latinos absolutely assimilate
well this is how bad it's gotten in the
democrat party though
of course a lot many latinos have
assimilated but the
main point here is english has become
controversial
assimilation in some quarters has become
controversial so to be an authentic
credible democrat today
you have to believe that the party's
views of just a few years ago
are now basically racist xenophobic and
hateful
this is insane now something similar
unfolded at duke university over the
weekend as well
the politically correct fanatics in
academia
put another trophy on the wall when
assistant professor megan neely
who headed up the university's bio
statistics masters program
was forced to step down from her post
this weekend
her crime in an email well she sent
to grad students last friday and in it
she said two faculty members had come up
to her
to complain about students loudly
speaking chinese and a common area
so she wrote that both were disappointed
that the students weren't working to
improve their english
neely's big sin was urging them to quote
commit to speaking english 100 of the
time
while on campus perish the thought again
it wasn't a slam on chinese it was
kind of a ham-fisted way of encouraging
folks
to speak our language language while in
our country
studying by the way at one of our
premier universities
now it was ultimately to help the
students compete for projects
and employment why is that a bad thing
the horror
again the accused profusely apologized
for her language offense
but it didn't matter the damage was
already done
now look as i've said many times you
know i speak russian i speak english
speak speak english usually time speak
spanish it's terrific for kids to speak
multiple languages
being bilingual trilingual that gives
kids a
huge leg up in this economy and a lot of
options
but at the same time english is our
national language
and folks who want to come here legally
should learn to speak it
there's nothing racist about saying that
at all
unless obama george w and pretty much
every american president
is also racist and if an american an
american who's shopping in a store
gets i don't know impatient when a
cashier can't speak english
that doesn't necessarily make the patron
a xenophobe or a bad person
they're frustrated you know i was
thinking today
what would teddy roosevelt think today
remember what he said so eloquently in a
letter read shortly before his death
that he had written
in 1919. he said in the first place we
should insist
that if the immigrant who comes here in
good faith becomes an american
and assimilates himself to us he shall
be treated
on exact equality with everyone else
there can be no divided allegiance here
we have room
for but one language here and that is
the english language
for we intend to see the that crucible
turns our people out as americans
of american nationality and not as
dwellers
in a polyglot boarding house
i want to become just a polyglot
boarding house it's not
just though that the english language
requirement can set off today's democrat
conformity police not just that
even a two-term vice president isn't
immune
biden joe biden was wrapped last week
for daring to say
a nice thing about a republican
i i i get in trouble i read in new york
times today that i
that one of my problems is if i were to
run for president uh
i like republicans okay well bless me
father if i have sinned
but uh um
but you know from right where i come
from
i don't know how you get anything done i
don't think they get anything done so we
start talking to one another again
so common sense from biden sometimes you
have to reach across the aisle
he got slammed for that in left-wing
quarters
i love going online to see what they're
all saying nutso
now continuing even a famous comedian
is forced to play by the shifting rules
of the left today
remember when it was announced that
kevin hart was going to be the host of
the academy awards
well the mercy crowd dug up 10 year old
tweets
and charged heart with being homophobic
so
even after he apologized and ellen came
out to support him
the left would not be satisfied
with all this being said and all this
controversy and all the way you
ways you've addressed it yeah is there
hope that you would host the oscars this
year
i i so that's the absolute no yes am i
hosting the oscars this year
well the litmus test now for headlining
the gig is now so difficult to pass
that the oscars will be hostless this
year
shock another one up for the sensitivity
squad nice going guys
all this demonstrates the democrats and
politics the media
and academia are zealous about enforcing
borders after all
their own they aggressively police their
own ever morphing code of progressive
ethics
and if you run afoul of them their
mercenaries will destroy you
in some cases even profuse abject
yes embarrassing apologies will not
suffice
so today you may be part of the cool
crowd
but tomorrow you're all disposable
and walking on eggshells to boot good
luck with that in 2020
and that's the angle